anh alo chào bạn
anh
ừ ừ
có phải tối ưu được cốt ngày hôm trước
cái cốt là học viện à điểm danh ạ người
không hiểu Bạn cho mình xem lại nhé
Anh chấp chọn cái thì chị ra hiệu dạng
giả sử là môn lấy được tiền anh rồi
nhưng muốn này vậy
Anh Muốn Nói
rồi hôm nay ở chưa có điểm danh nhưng
giờ sự là sự tôi điểm danh hai bạn này K
thế này điểm danh được rồi không ạ thì
bây giờ để hiển thị hiển thị lại cái
lịch sử điểm danh ạ thì thì hôm trước
tôi làm thì nó sẽ cơ chế là tôi sẽ hiểu
cho mấy ông quen với việc hiển thị dạng
mà không ạ Mà nhiều chiều Nếu nhiều ạ
indec này
Ừ tôi sẽ lấy à Lấy cái đi Ra đúng ạ sau
đó thì kiểm tra nếu mà giả sử là có có
giá trị thì mình sẽ truyền cái trường sa
tế ớt vào thiệp cầu là theo kiểu sơn nói
đi kiểu như hai thì chuyển vào và ở bên
fanpage thì sẽ hiển thị ra nóng lạnh thì
sẽ hiển thị ra là mình sẽ kiểm tra là là
nếu mà tồn tại này và và nếu nó bằng mục
thì sẽ check thì đoạn này tôi sẽ làm tối
ưu hơn cho mày uống xem đó là thứ nhất
là đoạn này nếu sử các bạn bị làm nhà tớ
đoạn xsat kiểm tra kiểm tra nếu có xong
rồi Kiểm tra bằng một như thế này nó sẽ
dài dòng với thể làm bạn này ngắn hơn
cái gì này
lấy ra cái tại vị trí thực key này mình
sẽ có đây này ghét này sao Tết này à
ạ sau đó thì tại cái vị trí trước kia là
như này nó thế là xong sẽ ngắn hơn rất
nhiều như này thì chị ạ
khi
chạy thử lại nhé khoảng vẫn như thế đúng
không ạ tương tự như thế thì sẽ có cái ở
đây như thế này
này nó sẽ xử lý như thế nào Cái này là
nó sẽ làm việc với mạc và kiểm tra trong
cái mảnh này tại cái kia là cái kia cái
này không ạ Nó sẽ nó sẽ kiểu nó không
báo lỗi khi mà trong trường hợp mà cái
kia à Không Tồn Tại nó sẽ không báo lỗi
gì cả
nó sẽ trả về là new Nếu mà trong trường
hợp mà không có không có kia thôi mà nun
gì với nhau không thể bằng một được kết
quả đây là đúng nhưng mà tiếp theo tiếp
theo đó là
ở đó là ở thực tế là hôm trước là tôi
làm theo kiểu như này là lấy ra điểm
danh ngày hôm nay này xong rồi lấy điểm
danh chi tiết theo từng sinh viên xong
rồi tốn marketing vào như thế này thì
thằng leo nó có cơ chế freeship rồi để
làm thời vụ marketing này rồi thì bây
giờ tôi sẽ thử làm cho miếng xem nha gì
à
thì mình sẽ chỉ đơn giản như thế này
thôi từ đây này
Loan cài flash Zip là xong tôi mới cài
copilot của thằng kiếm pháp của vì hôm
qua tôi sang cốt của trong máy anh Tuấn
Mạnh Tuấn thì hiệu trưởng ấy anh Chu Lai
oto thì xanh để mà đi bắt cho anh đấy
thì thấy ngon phết tôi sẽ thử dùng cái
cái này
ờ ờ kiểm tra Vision ship thì tôi thấy cá
nhân ở sân si tối ưu hơn ít nhất à ý
nghĩa là về
kiểu nó trong nó kéo ngắn gọn trong
chuyên nghiệp hơn nữa chỉ đoạn này mình
sẽ làm như sau mình sẽ thêm một cái ship
vào đây là
Ý mình là cậu lấy ra
anh ấy ra này
lấy ra xong trường hợp này rõ ràng là
một sinh viên có thể có nhiều điểm danh
đông ạ nhưng mà tôi sẽ thêm cái chú đây
là chẳng hạn thì rồi đấy điểm danh của
hôm nay thôi cho chắc chắn cái gì đó
nhưng mà gần như là khi mình lấy điểm
danh nhà luôn đi kèm luôn nên đi kèm
thêm cái á Ở thật tendon ID này Đây là
cách truy vấn ở đây nó sẽ là ông cách
khai báo ở đây Tôi nghĩ là nên để theo
kiểu nó là một chút ngoài nhiều đấy sau
mình sẽ Return valid à He has Won chỉ
một đôi nhé
em có ý của xinh vãi
anh em thấy gì đó
là xịn thế mà ở nhà hết mình sẽ chỉ cần
root cái thằng này
em đứng yên là mình sẽ
thằng này bạn chắc là mình sẽ e
ông thấy nó vừa có ý một phát ra hết cho
tôi không thế này xong bát cái này và
thích thì ông chị sẽ lách mỗi xa tất
cũng được nhưng thực ra là là
ck0 trong trường này nó bắt buộc phải
Schalke Cả thêm tiêu từng ID thì mới mời
quý được cái tháng này
A lô hàng ngày ra tôi thử cho mày không
xem bd thử mình không xem chứ đừng nếu
trong trường hợp mà ngày hôm nay có có
điểm danh nhé sẽ qua đây nữa à
à à
tendon thì nó sẽ còn như này giả sử có
sinh viên khác thì nó sẽ không ở gia
đình sẽ là nôn như thế này Đấy trong
thậm chí ở trong trường hợp mà không có
cả điểm danh ngày hôm nay thì tên này sẽ
không để đi ra ông ạ
Và bây giờ cứ giả sử mình cứ làm việc
với cậu Nếu có điểm danh hôm nay đã chọn
Ô kìa đây tôi sẽ là
anh ở đây mình sẽ phải sửa lại cái truy
vấn sửa lại cái hiển thị của mình không
phải Android ghét cái này nữa tôi sẽ tạm
vứt kén hàng ngày ra đây Tạm ra đây nha
ấy sau đó thì tôi sửa lại các bạn hãy
chút tạm xóa Dạo này đi này về Bây giờ
không phải là mấy mảnh nữa nó sẽ lỗi tôi
sẽ có sự định ngay
như này sau đó thì chỉ việc là lấy xa
tất
và bằng bằng1 như này là xong đó
Ừ cái này nó cứ bảo So sánh bằng bao giờ
ba ngày kệ đi cái đoạn này nó sẽ lỗi bởi
vì có có sinh viên chưa được điểm ra
nhưng nó sẽ bị báo lỗi là vào lỗi là sa
tế ớt nó không tìm thấy ở cái hàng ở Tây
Ninh người tên trong trường hợp nun đông
sẽ để boxxyno như thế này để
Ừ để gán cho nếu mà thằng này là nôn thì
vẫn trò được Kiểu như này này nó sẽ như
này ok chưa đấy
a tiếp theo tiếp theo đó là
tại sao vừa rồi tôi bảo là tôi vất Tại
thằng này ra đây đây là giả sử là có lúc
thì tôi làm việc với đối tượng này có
lúc ta tôi làm việc với mày Và thậm chí
ở Tôi cũng muốn bắt chước mà kiểu
Arsenal hiểu ngay cũng theo ai cả Ghét
nhiều như này thằng ezio có một thằng
rất rất hay
ở đó là ông thích làm việc với ế đối
tượng cũng được Ông thích làm việc với
mà cũng được sẽ có hàm nó là hàm
nó là hàm gì À
xem lại nhé hàng mày tên là
A
Better get a
à à
xe tải data game rất là xịn như này và
ông sẽ nghỉ theo kiểu Đây là khi
chấm chấm chấm ngay và thằng này làm
được việc được với cảm mà với cả đối
tượng rất ngon và đương nhiên là nếu một
hàng không tồn tại thì nó sẽ không vào
lỗi gì cả
data sét
à à
ở đây sẽ là
ạ bây giờ không truyền Hoài sáng nữa này
không cứ để tặng lại đã nha thì sẽ có
khi tôi đến này ngoại hình cho đến
mô
hình tròn đến tiếp sau tất cả
sao này không dài đợi thì À đây
ok chưa Bây giờ Bây giờ tôi Giả sử tôi
sẽ
a reverse lại cái cốt cũ cái cốt à à
Em có vừa nãy tôi tạm Vứt cái thằng này
Em ra đây đi
làm ảnh đúng chứ chứ chứ Đây
a b tôi chỉ cần sửa lại các bạn này là
vừa nãy ít cho làn xa tất này
khi tôi đến nay đi này
anh đúng không giống tôi đừng nói đi này
ở đây kỳ tại xíu Điện lại đi Này
tại sao này nó vẫn ra nếu thấy sĩ đâu đó
làm việc với mạng hay làm việc với đối
tượng thằng đa ta ghét lấy hộ trợ được
hết thế nên là mấy ông đỡ phải lo là lúc
mà ông chuyển sang đối tượng thì ông sẽ
phải dùng ai ghét ai dùng cái as he pal
Còn nếu mở với đối tượng thì ông lại
phải lúc thì dùng thêm optional để kiểm
tra Vân Vân không Đây là mình dùng tay
ghét Nếu là sử key này không tồn tại nó
sẽ không bảo lỗi gì cho anh cả
nữ ca sĩ nào ạ
à à
ở nhà bây giờ tôi nghĩ là nên dùng theo
kiểu là nên ship kiểu như này cho mấy
ông đỡ phải đỡ phải giỏi làm việc với
mảng đa chiều Nhưng mà thực ra đúng là
về sau vẫn nên làm quen với nhưng mà nó
chưa Thôi trở lại nha vẫn được đúng
không Mình sẽ chỉ copy cái này sang bên
này rồi nó là hai
ở thế là xong OK chứ
xe tải tôi vợ chỉ cho ông ấy Ông thêm
biết được thêm nó là mình thể dùng VSIP
cái cái này Tại sao lại là loát mà không
là Quýt bởi vì À
cái này sẽ tải thêm vào nó sẽ kiểm tra
thêm hộ cho mấy ông tải hơn vào
ta sẽ chuẩn nha
A và đây là nếu trong trường hợp mà là
có điểm danh rồi Nếu mà chưa có điểm
danh thì sẽ có bảo lỗi không sẽ không
báo lỗi gì cả Không ạ sẽ không báo lỗi
một cái gì đây cả
ở đây
ờ ờ
Mà tại sao nó lại hiển thị ra ở đây thế
này nhé
a a standing order by today today đã có
điểm danh hàng ngày đâu nhỉ Đợi tí nhá
Đợi tí nhé
à à
ừ ừ
ô tô đình
anh không hề có điểm danh cái Tại sao
thì tại sao lúc chả ra nó lại
Em có nhớ
em à Đừng Ô Đúng rồi nó bị một cái đây
đó là mấy ông để kỹ là nó vẫn đang mặc
định lấy ra bởi vì À bởi vì cái này nó
bị một cái đó là thằng Garena nó cơ chế
là mặc định nó sẽ lấy ra hộ ông kể cả
chỗ cũng không loạn nó như thế này cái
cách để ngăn chặn cái việc đấy thì thì
cách để ngăn chặn cái việc là nó tự động
thoát hộ cho ông mà tự động đoán này nó
sẽ sai bởi vì rõ ràng ở trong ngày hôm
nay thì không có nhưng nó tự động nó
thêm cho ông nó cứ kiểm tra xem có tồn
tại không thoát hộ cho ông cái hành gia
nó bị sai thế làm thế nào để ngăn cái vụ
nó không tự động đoạn như thế này thì ở
đây có
này
fan này
or two Last
Ship này này
Ê thằng level 8 nó cơ chế tự không không
loát với cái vụ này rồi đây cho nó bằng
chu cũng được về một cách ở trong mua đồ
hoặc cả trong đây
Ừ tao tao 8 đổ lên thì có thể cho cái
kiểu
event lazy-loading này này cái lazy loát
Dinh này tớ làm chị ạ Nếu giả sử mình
chưa with thì nó sẽ một vị nhưng mà khi
mà trong trong video mình à
harrison ship thì nó sẽ tự động gọi hộ
thì thằng này nó nhăn hội cho này
à à
đợi tí đợi tí
em có để disable này đi được
Có nhớ thằng à
al8 Nó có kiểu tắt nó ở trong Con thích
rồi thì phải
ngoài app đó là gì nhỉ
đi mua đồ season
à à
sao mạng thôi tự nhiên Lót cái gì cũng
chậm nhanh
a a
service cũng được nhưng tôi nhớ à Nó có
thằng này rồi
Ừ Nó kiểu nó hỗ trợ R8 đây đây đây đây à
hóa ra nó thêm đúng ra ngoài thật vậy
chưa Ok Ok
Không nhưng cái này nó kiểm tra là
kiểm tra Express nữa
chi tiết kiệm mình thể cài mặc định là
không cho nó nát cũng được không sao
đi xe buýt nhé
à à
không Lát hộ mình cài áo
Ơ cái thằng VSIP nữa Tại sao
ở đó
Ờ Ờ
cái này nó đang báo lỗi là
mình đang gọi đến hàng ngày mà mặc định
thời nắng tắt
Ừ thì nếu gọi ta ghét gọi thằng ngày
không có thì phải bỏ qua Kệ nó chứ nhỉ
thì sẽ
cho trò này đi
mình cơ mặc định loát nhưng mà mới được
kiện này hay với các bạn nó sẽ ăn luôn
thôi
I get a
vì vậy xem thử câu truy vấn của mình khi
mà mình là nếu thế Mình quyết luôn nhỉ
Thôi nghĩa tô vít luôn ở đây không cần
một lát nữa
anh
gửi tin nhắn để tí nhé Thôi sẽ cái để ở
đây này vào đây sẽ quýt à
thí sinh hát hoài luôn à
ừ ừ
thử đây đây đây xem mà câu truy vấn
à đây đây ở đây nó chỉ truy vấn được mỗi
cái á
à à ở
mỗi cài s thằng truy vấn này chứ không
phải chỉ vấn này nhỉ
thể là là nó chui vật những cái gì thế
thì cách để mình Los lại Xem truy vấn cụ
thể nó là gì rock và DJ knurse
thì mình sẽ chạy cái này vậy
thì mình sẽ chạy này thì xem thực sự là
mình truy vấn lắm Thằng này nó sẽ truy
vấn như thế nào
ơi mình có một cái là
em lấy toàn bộ cài lại điểm danh ngày
hôm nay này Bỏ qua Bộ này đi
thì mình sẽ lấy 1 cái là sư dance xà
phòng xưa đơn này và xếp sao fault and
student
em nằm trong danh sách này ok
ý với điều kiện là
Ê thăm từng này đi luôn gần nhau sẽ à
loại bỏ luôn rồi nhưng thế này đúng là
tốn thêm một cái chi vấn thật nếu không
thấy không Tối như một cái dáng thật
nhưng có khi cách ta đã Ta ghét ở đây là
không hay mình có thể dùng À thế Chắc là
vẫn phải dùng optional để
ở
đây để đấy Thử xem Arsenal chưa gặp này
nó ngon không nhé sợ Arsenal vẫn vẫn
giống nhau là
trên status
ạ sau đó đi Ở đây tôi
em tắt hay đi Chẳng hạn tắt hả ngày đi
xe máy
Arsenal vẫn lấy nó vẫn lấy sandan
Ừ thế thì tôi sẽ chơi trò này rồi chơi
mẹo này đi Ờ
tận một cái truy vấn nếu không thấy à
Xong rồi rõ ràng là trong trường hợp mà
thằng tendon này hả chấm Mình vẫn là mất
thêm về các truy vấn
anh
vào cái thằng
student attendance Golden để mccourt lấy
ra bọn mình không nên trường hợp đấy có
nghĩa là đoạn này mình nên làm như thế
nào nhỉ Mình có thể là mình loát thằng
này nhưng mà cho nó là rỗng
Ừ thì ổn
bộ phim xã à
là dẫm vào được
ừ ừ
anh như này được thì nó sẽ không tự động
thoát hộ rồi nha À
em bận hoặc đậu xanh
sẽ tiêu rồi quá này là gì nhỉ
à à
ở nhà đi
chắc lại ĐT
à
Vì sao rồi Hay này
à à
Ừ cái này có vẻ mặc định vẫn tự động lấy
á tự động lấy rằng tendon này có rồi kể
cả tạ tôi có đi giao hàng này nữa tự
động lấy
Em có chị nhỉ
đúng rồi Nhưng mà thực tế là tôi không
muốn không muốn bởi vì rõ ràng là gia sử
gia sử nhá là sử là điểm danh ngày hôm
nay không có thì tự nhiên mình ở mất
công thêm một câu truy vấn nữa làm gì Để
lấy cái điểm danh chi tiết làm gì để
chắc chắn hôm nay không có điểm danh thì
tự nhiên mình mất thêm các truy vấn làm
gì ông hiểu rõ không
muốn dùng cho tôi sẽ dạy mày ông hướng
đến dùng D ship và nhiều không trùng roi
chết à Kiểu gì nó vẫn chọn này
ở nhà Nếu em ở cái á mở cái disable phải
lazy lót xinh vừa nãy thì
báo lỗi
ở tại trang này đang bị lỗi
Anh tối nay
Em định bị lỗi này
Ê trái miện trai các đoạn này trong ô
buồn cười
cha mẹ trai cắt cái
ăn thịt biển anh ừ ừ
báo hộ mình nếu mà có vấn đề về Lady bác
xinh rồi
cho anh như thế này
số tự động gọi cái này
mình thôi là nó sẽ cho ấy sắp chuẩn hộ
thôi chứ không có có kiểu hỗ trợ cực kia
thôi chơi kiểu lại vẫn này chơi kiểu này
vậy hãy chấp nhận vậy
ví dụ Giả sử chọn vào kế môn đã có này
anh như thế tính là tôi vẫn thấy là
thằng data ghét kia ngon ta ghét à
Nghe ca nhạc Mình sẽ
là chấm status cho nhà không cần
optional gì cả hình ảnh
ở đó
sự tích Tích Bản
có ai chẳng hạn Một Mình
Anh đang đợi tí nhé tôi Tin tôi đừng
trách
là là tôi không hiển thị lại ca cũ ở đây
nếu mà có những ra sự có thì tôi nghĩa
đoạn này nên truyền cả cả cũ nó hơi bị
hơn này
thì tránh để mình biết là đã điểm này ra
chưa ấy nó lên là như thế này
sẽ thêm một cái lại attendant kiểm tra
đã điểm danh nghe chưa
ở đây là
ờ ờ
Ừ nếu mà có thì nó có điểm danh rồi thì
tôi sẽ ở đây một cái cấp chân đi à
anh alo set nghe luôn
à à
mà lấy sẽ là cậu đã điểm danh đi sẽ cho
là kiểu chụp cái dấu tích kiểu u
sự tích về mà ghét được
đi cho đơn giản à
hình ảnh này
tải sheet nhạc Nếu có yêu có
bây giờ sự lựa chọn cái môn mà chắc chắn
ra chưa điểm danh này sẽ bảo lỗi là
thằng này không không có họ thì đây mình
sẽ có Channel đầu ti optional thằng này
chưa này à
và tiếp theo đó nữa là mình phải Arsenal
cả hàng ngày
khi họ xyz
thế như thế này phải là ít ít ít
thế này
ấn vào đây là
ở eo thì là không này cho em ít người ạ
Không ạ
để nhập tiền ra cho nó này
ở Kon Tum lấp đất lên student
em có luôn nó phao
Ừ
đúng rồi nhỉ
Ở trên đây ngày hôm nay sao ế
ừ ừ
anh ra mà
à à
ơi các bạn hãy chơi trò chơi cá cảnh
ngay
chị xem thực sự thằng Hà Nội gây ra lỗi
đoạn này
thì mình sẽ bêđê cái
Có ai đi
thế này
thanden
ở Audi A6 đúng rồi đó
ở học viện Nhân dân
A6
nó
ở góc bếp sẽ status bằng hai Where ID
Moon
alo rồi
Ừ Tao quên mất với cái A class này mặc
định là nó sẽ đôi khi nó theo cái cột
cột ID của các bạn và vào đây thực tế
thực tế nhá đó là
ẩm thực tế là cái cột
Ừ cái cái bảng này cái bảng này thì nó
lại hai cụ ảo thuật 2 2 cột là kiểu dạng
là khóa chính chữa khỏi Một Cột là thằng
level thì có cơ chế là một cột Đọc khóa
chính là cột đấy sẽ là cột ID thôi nghe
nên là nó sẽ không làm được Kiểu này thì
đây
Ê hồi hồi đấy Tôi phải dùng cái gọi là
dùng cái để mà kiểu cho nhiều cột lọc
khóa chính là compose như thế này
a Combos
ờ ờ ờ combostik kiểu dáng đa đa cột là
một cái gì đó
như này xong rồi thêm chữ level để cho
nhiều cột lò khóa chính cùng một lúc
xe tải sẽ hiểu ngay
à Tôi nhớ tôi phải chèn thư viện và để
làm
chèn thư viện này nó ghi đè lên hồi này
Lazio năm rồi Làm rồi này nhưng mà bây
giờ là 8 thì vẫn hỗ trợ đúng cái tương
đối
lâu rồi
xem lần cuối cập nhật bản Tận năm năm
trước này có nhớ có mấy thằng mới hơn
này nhỉ
ờ ờ
mà ông cho nhiều cột nóng quá chính như
thế này thì sẽ có nhiều hàng mà nó sẽ có
vấn đề như là cách ông sửa cai được tùy
ông mới nên ông phải rất cẩn thận ông
mới lên sửa cái đoạn này
khi ban hành trước cập nhật bản trước
này làm như thế này cho nhiều cột lọc
quá chính này thì khi mà ông chạy cái
update across four five
Ừ Ok ở nhà hàng sẽ được này hỗ trợ
clazol 8 đấy ok
Cho
tôi xin Xem phim Đoạn này vào là được
không muốn và tràn trên thư viện thì ông
sẽ phải chơi cái trò Nó là kiểu như thế
này ông sẽ
anh lấy đôi nhà lấy ra cái Hằng Ok Thế
thôi
Đây mình sẽ que trước như thế này mày
đúng kiểu như trước này à
này đấy à
itneun là giờ sửa Nếu mà không có thằng
Black
Ừ thì ông sẽ lưu ông sẽ khởi tạo nó
không ạ Ông sẽ khởi tạo nó bằng như thế
này
A và gà ông class luôn được Đây là sẽ
chạy kiểu dạng led cũng được
à à
khi
nghe xong Còn nếu mà trong trường mà eo
đây thì ông sẽ là
Ừ ông xã cho update update trình điều
hành này thôi cũng sẽ update status kiểu
ngày bằng sáng tất sau đó cũng sẽ chạy
xếp
về cá nhân tôi thích kiểu cái này nó như
này hơn tôi thích Khởi tạ mới hàng ngày
xong rồi tôi sẽ cùng gọi thì thằng xếp
thì nó sẽ trông vẻ hay hơn thì còn một
thằng cu ghi ông thằng xếp riêng tôi sẽ
kiểu khởi tạo thằng mới hàng ngày theo
kiểu lưu nhà nhá
di truyền đúng kiểu ngày
Ừ tôi từng là đi tôi đừng ai đi à
xe tải
ạ sau đó thì ở đây tôi không gọi đến em
nữa mà tôi sẽ gọi sếp chuyện này luôn
này
em ở nhà
thì
nó sẽ là lực để tôi nói lại nha đầu tiên
always như thế này kiểm tra Nó tồn tại
chưa này nếu mà nó chưa tồn tại thì ông
sẽ tạo mới nó ông cập nhật vài thông tin
vào cho nó như thế này sau đó thì ông
đổi xa tốt cho nó cả hai trường hợp kể
cả class hoặc update Thì ông nên đổi cho
nó đúng không ạ
đó thì ông sẽ cậu xếp vào lại khi mà sếp
này nó sẽ mặc định là một là update
high-class đấy làm Chiều nhai cũng được
như này thì ông đỡ phải kiểu chèn thêm
một cái thư viện rồi Như này
Anh cho em thêm người thư viện cả ngày
nhưng ở đây ở trong trường hợp mà tôi
đang dùng và trên công ty rồi cũng dùng
Tôi dùng ở trên Coffee luôn đấy thì tôi
nghĩ à Cách này có một cách khác thì mới
ông thích đến mấy ông thích giờ sửa muốn
muốn là kiểu bảo mình có 2 cột là khóa
chính vẫn thông đều nha Vẫn không được
trả mãi ông sợ xem cái đoạn này trên như
thế này nhưng mà Seo quy tắc chuẩn của
L'Oreal thì thế này không đúng đâu Ồ kìa
theo quy tắc trần của thằng Model thì 1
A gọi là là bảng chỉ có nên một cuộc đấu
khóa chính là cột đấy Nên là của đã đi
tượng tăng à
đi chuyến này vàng
à hài cốt là quá chính đáng sợ nghe xong
thì bây giờ sẽ chỉ cần chạy cái lại
Altis Focus nó sẽ không bị lỗi nữa ở đâu
đầu tiên tôi cứ chạy lại bình thường này
mấy ông xe mà tôi còn bị lỗi nữa không
nha Rồi con bị lỗi này nữa không nha
chạy này không còn bị lỗi nữa đúng không
ạ Cũng chả biết cái gì À cái sai nhỉ
Ai Cập nhật thử xem
đợi tí nhé Đợi tí nhé
rồi nhỉ
là sao mày không lỗi nha
Xin lỗi nha mà cũng không nhìn anh được
à à
em chuyển giao thừa thử và cho Nói ngay
à
Ừ hình như là tôi điểm danh được rồi đây
A6 như là ca nó lẽ là tôi đang bị bạn kể
k ngờ cùng cái môn này k hay nó lên
trước rồi nhưng thời gian hàng chưa có
kê để tôi thử
điểm danh cho
thì nó phải môn khác đi
chưa có điểm danh không ạ tích tích tích
này K1 này Ok đã điểm danh là không ạ
tôi đổi nó thành nhà cái
đi ăn đêm lang Ok Hải Trang này món này
ok ok rồi nhưng đây là cách thứ hai mình
làm hôm trước trong vậy Nhắm cho chuyện
và trong được được hơn này áp bếp of
Late là mình sẽ
khi mình tự dùng telescope rồi mình dùng
t-stop cả clockwork để mà kiểu kéo theo
dõi theo những cái chữ vần đấy
ờ ờ
cho mình không xem luôn cũng hay mà
Anh bay là khi ở mình mặc định mình sẽ
que đúng kiểu như trên này kiểm tra nó
đã tồn mãi chưa Nếu mà chưa thì sẽ là
last Còn nếu không sẽ update theo cái
chương stop này tôi sẽ thử nhập hơn này
ở đó được luôn em thấy ngon
mình đổi nha đổi hết hàng nhé
Ừ
ok Tại sao vẫn đang nhìn đó
Ừ đấy tùy một trong hai cách của mấy ông
ạ Ông nếu mà ông muốn một cái đặc biệt
bằng hai bớt thì thường và có nhiều bảng
về sau của ông sẽ trả nợ một nó chơi cơ
chế là nhiều cột cùng là phá chính thì
mới ông nếu mà nếu mà Mấy ông muốn dùng
cái hàm update of grade kiểu ngay
Ừ thì thì méo bắt buộc phải chơi kiểu
dạng là thêm một cái như kiểu như này
còn không thì ông phải làm giống như tôi
vừa làm kiểm tra xem tồn tại chưa
Ừ nếu mà nếu mà chưa thì không phải tạm
mới nó đúng không ạ di truyền thông tin
và cho nó số ngồi ông truyền nốt những
thông tin một lại rồi không lưu gì mà nó
sẽ ạ Cái cái hàm lưu ở rất là hay nó sẽ
kiểm tra xem là nó sẽ update hoặc là
ai rất tùy tùy nó
Ừ nhưng mà cái này rất hay mà kẻ adata
class này có sẵn của thằng nào rất ngon
mà tận dụng được nó tốt phải chơi cái
chết yểu ngay Ok chưa
nay mình sẽ dậy lại quay lại cái webmo
giới nhưng mà tôi mừng tối vậy có hôm
trước thì nó sẽ như thế này Ok Bây giờ
mình sẽ bắt đầu quay lại cái bài học thì
Nga làm nốt cái web vui rồi nhé
Ừ chắc là kịp trước tháng 8 rồi sóng
cũng tương đối xong thì mà thử Đăng lên
thì mình không đăng CV thì các thứ mà
a a khóc tạm thời trước Đăng CV mà cần
nhưng mà không lên duyệt những cái mấy
ông xem những cái
việc làm cái thứ thứ
lấy là cái giá thôi Chị già Đúng không
à à
Anh Bối Rối này đi Cần này
tôi sẽ cài luôn Facebook cho mấy ông nha
bản chất là mấy ông thấy ra tôi cài thêm
cái đi Bắc ba nha để mà theo dõi thường
xuyên thỉnh thoảng mình sẽ theo dõi xem
là có những cái câu truy vấn kiểu như là
như nào rồi đúng ạ như này nhưng mà
mình đôi khi mình không
Ồ thông thường xuyên tiện theo dõi được
và đôi khi còn không có nhiều nơi không
dùng đĩa 3 giống như không Tôi tôi chẳng
ạ bởi vì a công ty tôi là cái fan thì
không dùng TP mà dùng view chẳng ạ thì
cái t Scott này làm cái cậu đêm thường
xuyên theo dõi
mọi thứ đang hoạt động như thế nào nhưng
tôi cá nhân tôi không thích dùng cái này
cái lưu lại mình là thằng t stop thì nó
sẽ lưu lại trong top ai nhé Tao bây và
thỉnh thoảng ông vì nó đã bên thỉnh
thoảng này ông nên xóa bớt đi không nó
sẽ bị nặng
Ừ anh em nhầm
Mở bài thằng học viện à
cách mũi rồi
à à
Minecraft rồi nó sẽ tạo cho tôi bây ơi
a glass Tinker gì đây
à à
đang làm gì mà lâu nha à
từ trước đang làm dở là đang làm à
À thì ra giá cá thứ rồi cũng tương đối
rồi thì bây giờ bấm nút này để reset này
Thực ra lúc này đơn giản lắm Nó thẻ à
chị sẽ Xong
nha hiểu quay trở lại cái
anh quay trở lại là xong
a cho xem
ở nhà mình sẽ hát ghép ở đây ạ
này
à
Tôi đang dùng cái bản miễn phí à
a a không phải travel travel
anh sex văn
Em gửi hình như nó gợi ý sau để xem như
không có cái này đâu
chị sẽ là inbox rồi
em lên à
ở đất ở
chị sẽ là app reconnect
à à
ừ ừ
để bổ mắt nào
bạn trong đống này Đốm không biết là ai
luôn
em có cái bản chất là bấm có thể à nó sẽ
ở lại cho xong
tin tức là sử ở Tôi sẽ mặc định Tôi cho
tất cả hai sẽ ra đúng không ạ Ok này bấm
mày reset nó ok chưa có gì cũng nghỉ vẫn
tranh có rồi này
bí ẩn chi tiết để xem lại đăng đúng
không ạ Mình sẽ xem đánh chi tiết
Ừ nó diện xe mày đăng chi tiết ở đâu nhỉ
cái hồi này nằm mơ tây du ký tà
Anh hiểu Xem Master Kids
ta có
Ừ chiều nay được nghỉ
à Xong rồi mình hiển thị cái cậu ạ những
cái công việc ở đây kiểu tương tự nữa
Rất là xịn thì tôi sẽ bắt chước cái này
nhá
ừ ừ
thay đổi không ở giữa này còn toàn bộ
mình cái bên cạnh này nó giống nhau thêm
cả cái thêm cái khung này nữa
các ngôi sao
à Không này về có bạn đợi tí cứ thử tôi
thử à
Anh xóa cái ở giữa này đi xem nó có
ô ồ sao Pika này à
xe Jeep dâu à Thử xóa lại đi nhé
à à
Ừ hình như là sai đấy kìa Thằng này nó ở
góc này
tự động tạo một tí nhé Đợi thức tí
anh xóa cả thằng ấy cho nữa thì
Ừ nó vẫn bị trắng ở bên này Ừ
thế thì tính ra là thế size 3 của tôi
đang say
ở đoạn bình tĩnh bình tĩnh
có size 3
Plus vào trong ngăn kéo container
site 3dpro đây
chứ không phải như này mới đúng này
Xin chào content nó phải ở đây
A và toàn bộ cái đoạn này
nhà đất vào trong tháng ngày
anh em đúng này xong rồi đít class rau
này sinh nằm ở đây
à hài này
ở
tại trang thì nó vẫn sẽ giống hệt nhau
thôi nhưng mà nữa sử Xóa toàn bộ hoài đi
thì nó sẽ phải
các bạn có được mà không được không được
à mà không được rồi
Ở huyện à
à
Tôi đang muốn tôi đang buồn là kiểu nó
sẽ
mà
Ừ vậy thôi nhé
anh ra sự thật sự sáng nay đi làm à
thấy nơi này à
mở rộng thế tạo thành sân là luôn á
à à
I mean dai ở đây vẫn có mấy nhỉ À thêm
cái là main phố Bắc anh xóa mainboard
thị xã
a pro monplay ý
ở góc battles đoạn nào à
học khiến cho thằng bé nhỉ
Ê thằng nên dai bé nhỉ
xe container nó to như này mà
I Pray nó tự nhiên bạn nha
sao vậy Buddy
I
By Me Anh có thằng này
a Marine begins
vợ yêu nhỉ
ở VN
à à bên mình không ở về container
ở VN ở ngoài
không
ở nhà rồi rồi rồi rồi thì container khi
nó nó thằng này nó to ra Ừ thế tôi không
quan trọng không ạ
u19 Nhật to cái này được không được
à à
theo thì mình sẽ
vì thế thị xã biết hàng ngày
cái này
cô dâu
em ở đâu này
ở đây là
à à
ở nhà ở Đồng Nai à
thì tại sao
à
cái gì gì đó vì tôi muốn à mình sẽ có
thấy một tháng nữa là có đắt thì thêu
Xem chi tiết ở trong này cái vô đắp thì
thêu
ờ ờ
Ừ ừ Nhưng mà nếu thế thằng view này Thực
ra sai nhỉ À không posst theo chứ em nhỉ
mở cửa hàng post này thì nó lại là để
render
a view open
ở bên này apartment
- peroxidase hiển thị cho kiểu dạng như
lai
ừ ừ
I would hiển thị cao Nha há
ở đây phải lạc posts
à à
ở
đây là một bài đăng này
anh cho xem
Ừ tôi muốn xem bài đăng chi tiết
rồi nghỉ tại một cái thằng có sửa đầy
chai rồi vậy Tablet p nữa sau
đỡ phải làm phước ta
copy đoạn này vào
mình sẽ có
ở đầu tiên ở đây Đợi thì đợi tí nhé đây
tôi có router này mấy cân này tự nhiên
là khi xem một cái pass một cái bốp xài
đi không ạ
Ông Bà mình sẽ chuyên Post vào trong như
thế này sẽ à đi theo em ạ và sâu thường
gọi hành mà nó sẽ ăn sâu nha Cái cụ thể
xem một thằng ở
về sau này
a public phân sinh nào
sau này mình truyền vào cụ thể post
du lịch cần
chấm sau như này xịt mãi trẻ mãi à
ê kê sau nghe được mà lại sẽ là đổi tên
cái này thêm sâu đi
à à
giao diện bên trang này
ở đó là
tem
ở đây nhỉ à
ở Tab cân tên ở đây là à À cái này hả A
gọi đồ được ảnh này yêu mình làm gì có
rảnh đâu nhỉ Mình có ảnh không nhỉ cái
nữa nhỉ
10 ảnh cho tao con tay này trái nghĩa gì
cả để Sao mà ừ
Ừ cái gì mình hiển thị cái này nhỉ Mình
Tôi tôi đang định là tôi sẽ đọc trước
cái file cái file này
Ừ mai nếu trong trường hợp file của mình
đưa nó đều là dai nhỉ à
300 bác này đọc trước rồi phải bấm vào
để mà tải file xem nhé em nhé Vậy thì
đợi thì
nghỉ lại lên topcv bắt chước vậy
Ồ thông tin thông tin chung này sẽ chỉ
ra bên bên đấy sau đó Mô tả công việc
thì bị giờ mình phải hợp lý sẽ được nghỉ
thông tin chung những cái chung ở bên
này
Ha ha cũng nhìn anh topcv nó có ảnh nào
đây không thấy có 700 ngon có mỗi logo ở
đây rồi đúng không Không đi tôi không
cần gì ảnh
Ồ Thông Tin ở thanh thông tin chung
những cái thông tin kia thêm cả những
cái biểu tượng này cho đẹp này ra hợp lý
sẽ hiển thị thông tin về bên này sao nó
mô tả bên này nếu có xong rồi file cái
bấm vào xem chi tiết được đơn giản à
anh đấy anh sẽ xóa cái đoạn này đi này
chắc con tên
à à
Ừ nếu thử nhé Để thử nhà thử à
ở
bên đất này
Ừ thì mình bấm vào Cụ thể một cái bài
đăng
35 Cụ thể một bài đăng
thể là đây
a router
cơ sở trên poster là sao ạ
đồng điệu cái này mình nên mình nên để
tông màu cùng màu đỏ hai cái cùng màu
tím gì đó tôi nghe cái này sẽ xóa đi rồi
nhưng mà tôi là cao sửa lại cùng một
tông thì tốt
Ừ ok rồi này sẽ nhảy sang bên A
con fix à
em mặc định hàng ngày đó của mình quay
đi Ở đây
Ừ thế bạn Swift này nó không tự động có
một lúc mà chỉ có trong cái à
Ừ cái có chứa
là
hit CF này ghé hay là Swift vẫn nhớ đã
phút này
ở bảng giá Switch vào trong ngày nay à
Ừ Vậy tí nha à
a Master ở đây
À không có gì cả thì sẽ có sách ở đây là
gì em thì mình sẽ mút vào trong ngày nay
học về chưa ạ
ở đó
ăn ngon rồi ngon rồi Dạo này mình sẽ
thay nó là chủ đề về đăng bờ biển
hôm nay sẽ là Boss
ở
hay khổ lắm sao mà gợi ý được biết gợi ý
được
Nó mất này
ở góc thay đổi Đúng rồi nhỉ puss In
Boots đúng rồi ạ
sản xuất của tôi rồi
7 có chấp hay chồng mà à
ủng hộ đã trống I would
anh sai nhỉ
Ừ đợi tí đợi tôi một tí
I
helped us bà này nó không đi ra được à
năm 2017 chuyển sang
poster day là Model posts
đi lễ rồi
khi bị delay chưa
anh chưa nói Chưa bị đi led tại sao
không đấy nhỉ
cách chuyển id sang ngày nó là giỡn á
có chấm phẩy gì chấm phẩy ghê chấm phẩy
I
ca nhạc
có
phải mình làm kiểu bình thường vậy có xe
đi vậy
vẫn hơi lại thằng em mặc định nó sẽ lấy
sẽ phải lấy posa người ông ngoại sẽ theo
cột ID là 27 lấy ra mày nghỉ à
Ừ dạo này mình xử lý size ở một chỗ nào
đó là nó không tự động lấy được kiểu đấy
Anh thường liên quan router nã cần
Naruto post nhìn truyền xa em không đi
sai cả best Sports
a what I
anh
không ấy được ca nhạc mặc kệ đi thằng
Trọng Thằng Trọng
thêm một bước nữa chứ mấy mình sẽ post
bằng A
file hay sao ý
từ nãy giờ buồn mắt rồi
chưa kịp thời gian
đây là mức giá này có gì luôn như bị có
mức giá là Đấy mình lại bắt chước cái
hôm trước để làm mức giá thôi
ờ ờ
hàng ngày luôn Mình không quan tâm cốt
cũ quan tâm mà chỉ cần
quay nhìn nó gợi ý ơi nếu không thấy nó
Vợ yêu không xịn và ai
Vì sao đi thôi I
họa xịn
có ngon không ạ
à à a Deep sân có nghĩa mặc định cho tất
cả nó cùng cùng hiển thị ra ấy
âm nhạc ở xa mà có mô tả ở
quên mất
qua mình là cái phần yêu cầu là mô tả
hay không ạ những cái này pin theo cái
gì đó tôi sẽ nhìn thấy cái bên này rồi
lại
còn cái gì nhỉ
à à
a cho tôi phải xem lại cái á
được là
chị sẽ location không có chọn ở đây
không áp thuốc hạ về đây có offline cùng
ngắm ở trường cấp 3 chẳng
khi bị công an hề làm phụ offline
ờ ờ
Nút này không cần này có phần mỗi phần
mô tả thôi phần mô tả được không cần nằm
trong cạnh có thể có thể cho mặc định
hiển thị ra đó mặc định thì ra như này
cho người dùng thì đóng lại cũng được
không sao
ở lại thì tôi à không không có thêm
những cái An dư ấy
à à Để xem nha kiếp Truyền đây đúng
không Này nội dung cái đít cúp trên đây
đúng không toàn bộ như thế giới này
những cái thêm phủ thêm đúng không
cách xóa bớt đi
cô gái toàn bộ Cái này nó sẽ đổi thay
nhà
là
what's weimann
wise woman I cô gái à
à à
ở
đây như là mình sẽ đổ thằng thằng tôi
qua mình ngay đây trong trường hợp nếu
có thằng này thì tôi sẽ thường hay làm
thêm là mình sẽ
anh gọi tí đã kêu rồi tí
Ừ cái này nằm trong cái đít nào phải
nhiều ít quá cả clip này là ngon sẽ là
những mà trong trường hợp này nếu có là
ngày thôi mình sẽ là ít
à Thế à
exchangeno1
là sao
e Mun ngon ngày chỉ cần Visa Thôi được
là sao ạ
Có phải bạn này là em đấy đúng
hình ảnh sẽ neset là sao
à à
xe tải nhạc nhạc sàn à
cô
gái thì sẽ không phân đi qua mình ký nữa
a big size cái gì chỉ đó này ở dưới thì
bỏ đi này
chị sẽ mặc định có cái nút ra à Thêm
chụp cả đấy à quên quên quên quên quên
quên quên quên của
con cái để hiển thị ra cái để mà
ô ồ
nút kiểu xem file như vậy Ở
ô ồ sao mà
Anh ở file nhiều có đấy à
cho sản luôn vẫn có
em không có lửa được
mở Zalo ai cần không có độ của mình đấy
Ừ biết rồi
ở Cairo Ai Cập nhưng không có độ của
mình yêu thật
Ừ mai Open cũng khá hay
CH2
anh xem còn cái khác nhỉ
là phụ đề
Em nói sao
ở Mỹ
a day
đã mua
thì cho đẹp rồi nhỉ
nó dễ hiểu để hiểu được là bấm vào sẽ mở
tắt mới thì
nhảy sang cái liên quan dri nữa
Ừ nhưng mà nó đâu có muốn tốt cho cả
ngày
các bác
I speak sinoca
Ừ cũng được
khi sex
a PDF
à à
Ừ cái này Google làm như thế này
Thế đợt ở thì có ai gọi
[âm nhạc]
Ừ cái này copy về à lại nghỉ trưa rồi là
nó lấy được cái biểu tượng ai cần đưa
nhỉ
Ừ thế nhé bố nó Xuân Từ từ quay gần đây
Khi nào lấy được tưởng tượng được nghỉ à
xe máy K đưa thời sự
i
felt i
We Are One another with some đó có kiểu
gen có độ của mình thôi à
có ai chắc có luôn sẵn có luôn à
cho nó sạch à
Ừ đợi Mỹ nhiều
chị sẽ là
Open đ
xe Open file à đã mở
iCloud nhìn trong nó hơi bị cần gần nhau
quá Thôi kệ ở đây sẽ là cái A này mình
sẽ Hz người đến đường link đừng dẫn của
cái boss đó đến bản chất là tốt Sẽ có
file mà đi không nhớ bố sẽ có file này
ở sông rồi nhảy linh của nó
a fine này hiện link nó sẽ hiểu ngay đó
221 là gì nhỉ
khi
đôi khi cái này nhược điểm thay như này
mình chẳng nhớ nó là gì
hay false à
251 lgd ok ok à
Ừ đợi tao tí đợi tí
Ừ tôi đã có làm vụ lấy file chưa có mà
đúng không Chứ có đúng rồi mình sẽ có
một cái nữa là đấy file đây này một hàng
sẽ chỉ có hát One sẽ là file này
ba ngày thôi bà
I have one
Heart One
right và
mình sẽ phải truyền thêm một cái nữa nhỉ
là khó không xe ô tô đi ở cho chị này
a file tôi sẽ wifi ở đây nữa
à à
xe
buýt
Mai đây nữa xong này
Bà ở bên này tôi sẽ họ file để lại đây
Ok Ok tại trang này
a
ring of non ha
Ừ cái bài đăng này không có Linh à ở đây
Bà đang mới không có Linh ngủ ngon
chứ không phải bàn học có linh khi mình
sẽ
à à
anh đi xe đi nếu mà có chó đến file Nếu
có thì mình mới yêu cái thằng này nó
được sẽ không lỗi gì cả nữa
rồi tôi sẽ có thêm ở đây là
ta ghét là lanh như thế này ok
bộ phim sẽ bấm vào mở 8 mới đó xin không
ạ
tiếp theo là tôi muốn có cái á
là mình
phải điều
và tôi sẽ cần có một cái kiểu
chờ đợi xem Mỹ tấn có nên con như thế
nào nhỉ Mình nên có cái kiểu nó bắt
chước tôi sẽ bắt chước cái giống cửa
hàng ngày trong hai cái nền nên nó còn
nổi bật ở bên tách biệt xanh ở bên này
cả ngày thì có không nên nó không có thể
kiếm một cái nó lên ở đằng dưới
em mặc áo kiểu tát ngay nên tác cho em
thôi hiển thị ra số hết ta người dùng đỡ
đỡ phải cẩn vào Tab em xem có nên như
thế
Ôi trời ơi có hay nhỉ Hay mình bắt chước
cái quay sinh kiểu ngay hiển thị ra ở
trên này nhỉ
Ừ đúng nhỉ
hiển thị ra
A gọi ngay trong
em nghĩ sao à
đây một cái kiểu nhà cũng được
Ừ cái Kiều à
a cho về thôi cứ nước hết đã
Ừ thì nhớ hết
em hết rồi
xem nhé ừ ừ
ấy mà nên tôi tốn một tí thôi
ở ngoài tự nhiên về cứ để ngồi nghĩ ko
nên mệt kinh khủng
mà sao ờ ờ
nhé Tôi sẽ bắt chước Xem thằng này làm
được gì nhé
xe ôm hay về đâu nha
xe ôm về cái tự nhiên ăn ngay dùng luôn
cố của nó cả
Ờ
kiểu vừa rồi giống tiêu rồi nó một cái
danh sách
ờ ờ
dùng cái này thật ờ
Ừ mình rãi cậu từng từng cái từng cái
kiểu ngay
xem có vấn đi à Ừ đúng là ngừng đấu mà
mình không có ai làm file khác tự một
thằng tự 11phan lên thành ra rồi Trông
rất củ chuối
bộ phim sex
ở những đường Chiến gì nhé à
anh alo em phải mình hiển thị có phải đi
ở dưới nữa Kệ đi à
Company ở đoạn này rồi
a Company Y sẽ hiển thị ra đây rồi
à à
khi mua công an ngồi làm giao diện cùng
mình ạ của mình chỉ hợp và các em ạ
nhà mình có Company ID mà sẽ cần à chị
ra Company ở bên này à
cho xem
cả ngày dưới này
cho mấy dưới cái À cho facial này mình
file này
Ừ ừ một cái á
được mình nói vãi cả trường ra được cả
có đề xuất ra Company luôn này xin với ạ
là sự thật
kiểu Company name luôn ạ
khi đôi nha hatred này nó sẽ nên nhảy
đến cái trang để xem Company để xem
thông tin Company nhưng mà Tạm thời tôi
thể chống đã làm chưa có gì đã
tính sao thì sao
cô gái kiểu nhà bài bài gì đó tạo bởi ai
cái gì đó cũng được à
phụ trách trách lâu cũng hay em xem nhá
xem à
a location mình hiển thị cho nhà chưa
đúng không Trên thị location
trông làm trắng đời ở đây nhỉ
à à
em
mất công nhận nào nó xị
à à
là nó sẽ à Ghét location ở đây sẽ có
A phẩy phẩy alo
ý tưởng này
công nghệ thuật phải lại đi
ở trong gà được được rồi Đừng nói kiếm
đi nhé Đồng ý kiến đi vào sửa nhé Tôi
thấy tôi không thấy đẹp nhưng mà xin
thấy hết cả năng rồi à
ừ ừ
này không ạ Nhớ là cái trò remote đây bồ
này mình để nó gì nhé
boss bị mốc
ai bổi năm
a cho phép remote này dynamic này
ờ ờ
vì sao mình sẽ hiển thị ra nó là chữ
Ừ mình rãi hiển thị nó ra là chữ
anh nghe xem
chị
sẽ làm kiểu này nhé
Hàn Quốc remote
có bồ đại đúng không này do cái nó nó
đang kết nối vào kết desk bây giờ mình
tại sao nó không gợi ý nhỉ à
nên report table nên mua remote p.bồ lên
ok à
chị sẽ ghét cái tôi sẽ tạo một cái ghét
ở đây
từ
trước đây
A là
cho phép primo table
Napoli năm thì sẽ ghi 3 remote
- 2 bồ ngay sau đó thì mình sẽ
Ừ cái này khi lấy ra nó sẽ là kiểu Nó là
xuynh kiểu chữ như này luôn thì tôi muốn
mà sẽ cách nhau bởi đổi cái này bằng dầu
cách này xong rồi viết hoa mọi chữ cái
đầu thôi còn những chữ sau sẽ vết thương
thì sẽ
có ai sẽ là sự đây à Cậu kỳ đây đúng
không
Tôi sẽ test cho mấy ông xem thử lại cách
con trâu lâu nha - peter nói em cái tôi
thử có ghi ở đây cho mấy ông xe luôn nhá
thì ở đây sẽ bằng à
a boss remote Playboy năm đời không xử
tôi lấy đúng thằng này đi ngủ chứ Tôi
tên thằng kia về trong xem này
chị sẽ là hai đúng không
Ừ đợi tí đợi tí ghét
I grew mai kia à
ở nhà Diệu xảy ra
Ừ anh hết kỳ bài báo lu ý nhỉ
có tỷ lệ tỷ lệ gì
đây nó sẽ ra chữ v emoto Lead đúng không
Nếu tôi muốn sửa nó thì nhất là tôi muốn
đổi cái này anh dấu cách sẽ là kiểu à
expro ngay Ê tụi nó ngay
A Way có ý xin mà ai
thì nó sẽ
trả về nó sẽ à nó sẽ có hai từ có hai
chữ như này đúng ạ xong rồi tôi sẽ viết
tôi sẽ đổi cái từ này
cho chúng hẹp ơi đi
Ừ
cái gì đấy
ờ ờ
Ừ Ok bây giờ rồi YouTube xóa sư help me
có số chính này tôi sẽ có muốn đổi số
Trinh thành cái
lâu rồi
Khi hấp
Khi FED chỉ có phốt thôi
em đi làm gì
nhà nhé
Ê bà
cho mọi mọi từ ngoại từ trong Vì sao
phải Android để tôi sẽ là này mình sẽ có
Ừ Đợi thì đợi tí cho sẽ thôi ở cái này
chưa đã
từ ngày tôi thử là
nhé
em có nó sẽ cho biết hàng chữ thường của
tôi rồi thì tôi muốn
Ừ cái chuỗi của tôi sẽ ngay sinh này nó
thì ở chỗ chồng này
tôi diệt cái thằng Android này
anh
sẽ cầu
chị sẽ truyền cái chỗ này
anh ta
thế này vào đây
nhìn này vào và cách nhau bởi dấu cách
tự nhiên rồi sẽ cách nhau bởi dấu cách
đó là
ngày cũng được
Ừ cái sau đó đi
Vì sao nói chuyện nào tôi trả về thằng
sinh gửi cho anh nha à
ở đó Thế có nhiều mẹo nữa để làm cái này
những thể cho trò là hair mesh
cho iMac được nha area
lại xong rồi
dùng cái hang này cùng một lúc hai hai
cái cùng lúc tôi nghĩ cái này cũng là
một cách
Ừ nếu thể tác dụng cửa cả hai cái có bị
nhược điểm đó là thừa về dấu cách ở cuối
đấy Nhưng mà không sao sử dụng cách
Chẳng sao vấn đề ở đây cả copy cái đoạn
này đây
thế này
Anh xóa đi chứ giờ tôi đã có một cái lấy
remote lên ngon lành rồi về nhà
anh
không được Mai mốt thấy buồn em Đúng rồi
nhỉ
du lịch thi đấu tin
guest remote temple ultraview
Anh xài đâu vậy
a name and review
em mua thẻ Vũ ở đây có gì ngu nữa
Ừ Đúng rồi hình như là nó nôn nó đang
luôn thì
cho xem
ở đâu nó ba mà nó là 3 giờ thì đây kia ở
đây ạ
à à
nó không nhảy vào cái Hà mày luôn Nếu
không theo dõi Gọi cái hả mày đăng sai
bộ remote table a'pieu
ca nhạc post gọi remote thay bồn êm
à à sex
cho Nokia mình gõ sai chính tả ngay từ
đầu nó không bao gợi ý lại chuẩn độ
chính tả mình đâu Ờ ờ
bộ remote table name
i ki
ở đôla jit ngày không ra hình như là à
Nó lại ra số cái nhỉ Mấy lần bị như này
rồi
như thế mình sẽ phải quy ước Cái này là
số đi
ừ ừ
vì lý do gì ở Mỹ sửa hình chữ nhỉ
hình ảnh
anh có thể có thể dùng play cái này
thành cái dấu cách đúng không Ừ nhưng mà
ông vẫn phải coi bản chất là tôi Tại sao
tôi biến nó thành mà Bởi vì tôi muốn
giết từ từ nó thành chữ kiểu
ông dùng ghi khách để mà thay đổi chữ
viết hoa chữ viết thường luôn đã có thế
thì nhưng mà nhưng mà có chữ viết hoa
mỗi chữ cái đầu ra sao
các bạn đấy để phức tạp hơn
Ừ ông Ông hiểu ý tôi không chữ Office
của tôi viết hoa ấy còn nhưng ai cơ viết
hoa cả ngày khi ông định vieplay mỗi
ngày đúng không
ê ê Asiad có không ai đi ngủ sửa xe mình
thì phải làm bằng à
à Mình mình đang xử lý các thứ thì mình
không chơi trò sẽ hết để đây mà còi like
rồi đấy nhớ đúng bạn nói cũng có một mẹo
một cái một cách một cách đúng rồi
Anh định viết hoa chữ cái đầu cái gì nó
đúng không
Em đang định làm tiếp vào cái gì nhỉ à
anh có thể có Park hay mày không đâu ạ
ỉa thì mình sẽ kiểu check là It's part
time không ạ sẽ là vào này mình chỉ được
Chắc thôi là Park Ha mày
ca nhạc Cái này tôi nhớ da size in mà
mình sẽ là
mãi
không ạ
a tiếp theo là
Ninja remastered full series đi qua mình
that ends
a static and thì tôi nghĩa nó sẽ nằm nên
nó nên nằm ở cái chỗ chỗ này ấy không
phải chỗ này number artecan Nếu có Không
ạ Đừng có thì mình sẽ thì ra đây một cái
lại ít
ít thép boss à Nếu nó là
Ừ nếu mà nói thế đi xe đi xe
a number apk Nếu có 5pf đi cần thì mấy
thì ra cái này
à à
chị
sẽ hiển thị là em ít nên ý Xác ngoạn
bạn tôi rủ tôi đi nhậu
a cho tôi chuẩn bị nghỉ gì đây mình anh
em ứng dụng được hết rồi
Ừ Ok chả để buổi hôm sau tôi ngồi làm
tiếp cái đống anh nhá Hôm Sao rồi tôi sẽ
đầy tặng cốt ngày hôm nay đã mấy ông
cũng về tôi nói qua lại từ hôm nay với
tổng kết thì sẽ là hôm nay á t-score thì
mình mới cài nhưng mà chưa động mấy này
mình
mình có kiểu làm thêm Chắc làm thêm Chủ
yếu là dịch vụ vừa nãy tôi xin thời gian
cho sẽ hết và mình làm thêm á Đúng rồi
hôm nay là bởi vì còn cả cái được tiếng
đâu đấy tôi ngồi tôi làm cái bên học
viện tối ưu với học viện nữa không ạ
ý cho con cái bên này thì mình mới chị
vẫn yêu mình mới chỉ làm mỗi giao diện
là nhiều chứ có gì mấy ông ạ Chưa gì mấy
ở mức tương đối nhưng chưa gì mới cả
Không ạ
Anh ở buổi hôm sau mình mới làm tiếp nhé
anh cũng cũng một tiếng 40 phút rồi về
sau nhé Tớ nghĩ là cái cứ tiền trình này
làm thì chả tầm mà Đúng kiểu đúng đến
tháng 8 đầu tháng 8 có những trang web
để tương đối để cho mấy ông tôi sẽ đăng
lên trang web để mình không thể truy cập
vào để không thể xem ok không ạ thế nhỉ
anh làm sao mấy ông nha à à